hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
taten welt ich erfreut wieder ein rezept
für euch was sich nicht nur super gut
aussieht sondern auch super toll
schmeckt ich mag es auch rezepte die
einfachheit zu stellen sind aber dennoch
was fürs auge sind wurde einfach jeder
sagt mensch wie hast du das wieder
hinbekommen
und die sagen zeig ich euch natürlich
auch immer gerne weil es für euch auch
besonders gut ankommt ich habe mich also
heute für einen kranz entschieden mit
hackfleisch füllung und da kann sich
wirklich selbst ein herzustellen es auch
sehr gut vorzubereiten
das heißt wenn ihr bis zum beispiel für
gäste machen wollte besonders am ramadan
zum beispiel könnt ihr das mittags
vorbereiten und abends einfach nur noch
in den ofen schieben oder ihr bereitet
es morgens zu und können mittags in den
ofen geben und ich werde heute einen
plunder tag nehmen einen fertigen
um euch zu zeigen wie es mit dem geht
und ich werde ich aber auch in der
nächsten folge eine flunder tag selber
machen und euch dann auch zeigen wie man
diese hat diesen hackfleisch kranz auch
mit vegetarischen zutaten machen kann
ich habe hier jetzt also meiner zutaten
und zeigt ihr euch mal ich habe 200 das
sind jeweils 400 gramm ich denke ich
brauche aber auch nur einen
das ist ein rechteckiger da ist 37 x 25
cm groß hier habe ich für die füllung
400 gramm hackfleisch dass ich als
rinder hackfleisch eine zwiebel 2
knoblauchzehen 1 halben bund petersilie
habe ich schon klein gehackt etwas
pfeffer hier ein esslöffel tomatenmark
und teelöffel paprika marx muss nicht
sein
aber schmeckt natürlich besser hier habe
ich ein paar gewürze und zwar einen
teelöffel salz
hier habe ich etwas gummi und viertel
teelöffel ein teelöffel chiliflocken die
sind nicht so mega scharf das sind die
aus einem türkischen supermarkt hier
habe ich etwas kurkuma das ist auch im
tarifgebiet drin das sieht man auch an
der farbe muss nicht sein aber ich finds
lecker und hier habe ich noch zwei
esslöffel oregano getrockneten könnte
auch frischen benutzen und dessen jetzt
so meine gewürze meine zutaten ihr könnt
es aber natürlich immer anders
abschmecken so wie es euch am besten
schmeckt die füllung wird jetzt egal wir
es ja dann später gemeinsam mit dem teig
in den
geben und dieses hackfleisch besitzt
vorgegarte werden damit auch später
richtig durch ist deswegen werde ich das
jetzt hier am braten in der pfanne
einfach ohne fett weil das rindfleisch
hat er schon genug und ich hab das
übrigens aufgetaut also ich habe auch
immer hackfleisch im gefrierfach und las
ich dann an den kühlschrank auftauen
jetzt können wir richtig schön scharf an
trafen allerdings ist für mich schwer
klasse das immer schön darauf gucken
okay und in der zwischenzeit werde ich
jetzt die zwiebeln fein hacken
ich habe jetzt schon halbiert und taxi
mit meinem alles schneider geschnitten
diese hier gebe ich jetzt direkt in
meine pfanne
ich brauche jetzt auch den behälter
obendrauf nicht weil ich direkt benutze
wieder rühren
man gebe es einfach direkt mit rein
so spart man sich dann einfach das
waschen des auffangbecken behälters
danach ist sowieso direkt weiter genutzt
und man hat einfach ein arbeitstag
weniger
ich mache es einfach schön rühren und so
lasse ich jetzt dieses fleisch mit den
zwiebeln einfach so etwa drei bis vier
minuten braten bis die zwiebeln einfach
etwas vlasic und nach zwei bis zehn
minuten geben als die restlichen zutaten
mit rein
mit pfeffer würzen gezieltes auch wenig
sinnvoll
petersilie mit rein oregano an die
gewürze und jetzt noch tomaten und
paprika markieren wird es noch mal und
damit sich die gewürze jetzt gut
verteilen gebe ich jetzt noch etwas
wasser mit rein was ist noch mal ganz
kurz aufkochen und las auch das wasser
gleich wieder verdunsten also das soll
ja keine soße werden sondern sollen der
feste masse sein und nur aus dieser
hackfleisch maße bestehen
ihr seht auch diese tolle farbe durch
dieses kurkuma wird es so schön gelblich
und dann ist die füllung auch fertig
die lasse ich jetzt hier kurz hier auf
der seite stehen lasst sie abkühlen und
dann kümmere ich mich um die teigplatten
jetzt muss ich meinen tag vorbereiten
dafür nehme ich jetzt den boden einer
springform und fette ihn ein
ich nehme da jetzt dieses back fence
dafür und es ist ein straight ist auf
rein pflanzlicher basis
es ist also vegan und da sind wirklich
nur pflanzliche bestandteile drin da ist
alkohol nur als treibgas mit drin also
dass dieses pflanzenöl auch nach draußen
kommt aber diese alkohol kommt nicht mit
den lebensmitteln in berührung
also da könnt ihr euch dann sicher sein
da ist auch bienenwachs mit drin das
riecht man auch wenn man an diesem wenn
man daran mal richtig mal nicht nur auch
richtig das bienenwachs und das ist
schon richtig tolles back trance prey
was ich verwende
und das hier ist übrigens jetzt mit 32
er formen und stell dich jetzt kurz zur
seite habe jetzt hier meinen blumen
datei also diesen großen tag schon
ausgerollt und nehme sie etwas mehl auf
die matte und gibt da mal kurz den teig
zu der ich immer so dietrich und freund
noch ein bisschen mehr drüber
ihr könnt auch gern noch mal drüber
rollen und ich werde jetzt noch etwas
dünner ausrollen
es funktioniert auch super gerade das
dann auch helfen müssen wir das hier in
zwölf dreiecke schneiden
das heißt ich werde es jetzt einmal
halbieren und dann eben noch mal
schneiden
ich werde es jetzt hier einmal halbieren
ich nehme dafür jetzt meine teig karte
weil man auf dieser silikon material
nicht schneiden die gitter kaputt und
zwar müsst ihr jetzt dritteln hier und
hier
hier muss ich noch mal zusammen
pflastern
und diese sex rechtecke werde ich jetzt
zu dreiecke schneiden also einmal
diagonal durch
jetzt nehme ich meine bank unterlage und
gibt es jetzt hier drauf alle drei ecke
die sollen etwas überlappen genau
einfach immer gucken das jetzt in der
mitte hier müsst ihr euch so ein kreis
denken könnt euch auch meine finger so
hin mal
und man könnte theoretisch auch statt
einem rechteckigen blätterteig oder
plunder teig auch einen runden nehmen
weil dann kann man das einfach halbieren
und eben zwölf teile rausschneiden aber
wie ihr seht funktioniert es so auch
super und jetzt nehmt ihr euch eure
füllung und ich habe jetzt hier auch
einen ice portionierer das ist jetzt
nicht da bin ich gesucht habe
ich hatte mal irgendwann einen mit
seinem aus werfer der ist perfekt wenn
ihr keinen hab ich es auch nicht schlimm
das geht auch ein einfacher esslöffel
und zwar nehmt ihr einfach eine menge
mit diesem portion ehre oder esslöffel
und geht es hier darauf lust daran dass
auch ein bisschen in form drücken also
immer auf eine ecke
und jetzt beginnen dir einfach irgendwo
und nehme durch eine ecke schlag 10 über
und neben durch ein werkzeug zur hilfe
zum beispiel sonntags aber und steckt es
dann hier rein und dann einfach immer
weiter
ich schiebe das jetzt noch ein bisschen
zusammen und jetzt habe ich hier in
algier mit ein bisschen milch und wird
es jetzt einfach noch bestreiten
damit der teig nicht austrocknet und
auch schönen klang nicht
du darfst mir helfen römer einfach ein
eigelb und zum mini schluck milch super
nicht ab da ja das darfst du mutig zeigt
dir wie beobachtungen
damit der teig nicht austrocknet und
eine schöne farbe und glanz bekommt
abdrücken
diesen teig diesen kranz werde ich jetzt
bei 180 grad ober und unterhitze für
etwa 25 minuten backen
und in dieser zwischenzeit werde ich
schon mal einen salat zubereiten
für meinen salat benutze ich jetzt
folgende zutaten da können durch alles
nehmen aber ich mache jetzt einfach so
ich habe hier etwas eisbergsalat eine
gelbe paprika eine tomate so nett so
eine paprika hier eine zitrone eine
gurke eine karotte und aus diesen
zutaten werde ich jetzt einfach einen
bunten salat mischen und mit diesen
salat möchte ich dann den innenraum des
ringes führen also so bisschen dekorativ
anrichten
jetzt nehme ich hier meine paprika hier
gibt es einen trick um ganz wenig
fruchtfleisch zu verlieren ihr drückt
einfach hier oben diesen strunk ein so
und dann habt ihr das kerngehäuse auch
schon entfernt
carlotta wird geschält die gurke werde
ich jetzt nicht schälen und ihr habt ihr
ja schon in meinem letzten video
irgendwo mal gesehen ich habe diese
stretch es hier in verschiedenen größen
und wenn ihr zum beispiel so eine gurke
habt könnt ihr ganz einfach mit einem
stretching damit sie nicht austrocknet
überziehen
und dann braucht er keine folie mehr zu
benutzen sondern könnte es einfach so in
den kühlschrank stellen
und bei so einer großen paprika kann man
entweder einer schüssel nehmen oder die
paprika einfach da rein steckt dann ist
die nämlich auch geschützt vor dem
austrocknen und die gibt's jetzt
mittlerweile in meinem shop da haben wir
ganz viele danach gefragt und deswegen
habe ich jetzt auch aufgenommen
die findet ihr im bett und ich finde
wirklich super praktisch nicht nur für
obst gemüse und lebensmittel sondern
auch für wenn man so viel auf reisen
geht kann man das ein shampoo damit
verschließen
und da könnte einfach mal das maimarkt
video anschauen da habe ich euch sehr
bereits gezeigt die paprika hat mir ich
jetzt wird sie lieber bei der tomate
nehme ich jetzt eure die schüssel weil
ich nicht will dass sie herum spritzt
und die karotte werde ich raste jetzt
mein zweites gebacken ich habe nicht
ganz die zeit gebraucht ich habe es etwa
jetzt drei minuten früher ausgemacht und
so sieht der kann jetzt aus warte nicht
wieder mal zeigen richtig schön also
wenn es schön goldbraun ist dann ist er
fertig und hier seht ihr auch den
unterschied wenn ich jetzt ein
blätterteig genommen hätte wäre er jetzt
da unten nicht so schön aufgegangen der
plunder teig ist nämlich eine mischung
aus hefeteig und blätterteig und
deswegen geht er auch schön auf und wird
trotzdem so fein patrick das was ich
jetzt hier einfach kurz stehen und in
dieser zeit welche jetzt meinen danach
fertigstellen mit dem dressing an machen
und dann ist alles schon sehr wir bereit
ich habe auch ganz gern immer ein
bisschen rot pohl mit in meinem fahrrad
das habe ich jetzt noch nicht da aber
das könnte wirklich alles benutzen was
ihr gerne habt ihr könnt auch zum
beispiel in den bauern salat machen mit
ein paar oliven und feta käse schmeckt
auch alles super ich werde jetzt die
marinade noch machen und zwar nehme ich
immer ganz gern mit ohne und auch schwer
kann ich dann auf diese stretch es
benutzen damit die zitrone nicht
ausläuft und nicht austrocknet und ich
mag es ganz gern wenn der salat sauer
ist weil gerade zu diesem gericht zu
diesem herzhaften und würzigen zu diesem
fleischigen passt einfach in sehr sauer
salat super gut dazu ich schmecke ich
meinen salat noch ab ich habe hier noch
etwas kräuteressig ich habe zwar auch
schon die zitrone mit dabei aber ich
nehme auch immer gern kräuteressig den
natürlich immer frisch gemahlen der
schmeckt einfach am besten natürlich
etwas salz des salzgitter erst kurz vor
dem servieren drauf geben weil ansonsten
der salat zusammenfällt und olivenöl
also ich gibt auch keine mengenangaben
weil ich auch zu dem salat keine
mengenangaben gegeben habe das muss
einfach wir darüber abstimmen wer hat es
gerne hart das ist jetzt dieser
kräuteressig die nicht genutzt habe den
finde ich sehr lecker und ich mag auch
immer ganz gerne dieses alnatura
kräutersalz das ist nämlich ohne riesen
hilfe also ohne diese trennmittel und
natürlich auch ohne geschmacksverstärker
und alles rein natürlich und da sind
einfach richtig tolle kräuter drin
das ganze riecht lecker sehr würzig
immer probieren und das gebe ich auch
immer gerne zu einem salat mit dazu
denn salat lasse ich jetzt stehen und
kann jetzt ihn mit einem ring
jetzt kann ich meinen gericht servieren
und das ist natürlich ein gericht was
super toll aussieht und wenn man grad
kalt oder zur fastenzeit riecht man auch
seinen gästen was tonne servieren etwas
was schön aussieht
ich gebe es jetzt einfach in den schönen
teller jetzt könnt ihr müsst ist
natürlich nicht aber ihr könnt es jetzt
schön servieren und eigentlich mit märz
in salat einfach mit dem löffel hier
einleben
aber ich möchte jetzt nicht das datum
aufweicht wegen diesem dressing
deswegen nehme ich mir einfach noch ein
paar salatblätter und legt die wie so
eine kleine schale hier herein
damit diese flüssigkeit nicht sofort
durchkommen also irgendwann wird sie
durchkommen weil ich ja nichts festes
aber ich möchte das jetzt einfach ein
bisschen verhindern
und ich gebe das jetzt hier ein
und wenn ihr möchtet bröselt jetzt
einfach noch ein bisschen feta käse
drauf etwas bear stearns oder etwas
mozzarella und den restlichen salazar
wird ihr einfach hier in der schale mit
dazu alles passt ihr da nicht rein und
ich will auch nicht überfüllen und so
habt ihr ganz schnelles sehr einfache
und sehr sehr schönes gesicht gezaubert
sieht toll aus oder was wir gemacht
haben dieser mir raten hunger die darf
das jetzt nämlich probieren und dieses
rezept gibt es natürlich auch
nachzulesen auf festen welt.de
ich wünsche euch noch eine ganz schöne
zeit freue mich natürlich wenn ihr mein
video teilt und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder zwiebel schmeckt
aber später ganz lecker aber als kind
hast du die cbm roh gegessen beispiel
das nicht mehr da schon mal reingebissen
wie in ein apfel crew gehört stimme aus
dem mund gestoßen können
dies haben ihr wart weder zwiebel
gegessen
wir benutzen sie jetzt mal super und wo
kommt der sitz in mülleimer
die schicksale